what's up everyone my name is Eric Davis
we are here live at 2018 San Diego
comic-con and you know I have been doing
comic-con for many years and there are
movies that you come and you look
forward to seeing and then there are
movies that you camp out for there are
movies that are among the most
anticipated to ever grace the Hall H
stage one of those movies without a
doubt is Aquaman so what's going on so
we're at Comic Con we're gonna do Hall H
is who hasn't been here yet it's kind of
nice to be able to say at this stage of
my career this is a first
because I've done most things I have to
say but this is a forgetting in front of
7,000 screaming fans that are looking
forward to seeing you a movie is
probably an experience that is
unforgettable is just that energy I'm
dying to see it that's why we do
experience it with a fan that's yeah so
now Jason you've been playing Aquaman
for a minute this is like your third
technically your third appearance as
Aquaman what the fans for this movie and
I see it on social media fans are just
rabid they want to see this movie they
wanted to Bauer it what has been like a
memorable fan interaction for you okay
Aquaman hasn't been known for his I mean
his costumes his unique costume a lot of
people on shows and they made fun of
them so it's very I'm always the
original og fans are very the very tight
orange and green and it's always they've
got like a little rubber ducky seahorse
thing around them so that's always
interesting when they come up to
different than you know what the old
comic books used to be it was very fun
to have them go like we really you know
that they accept me and and love love
the new okhla make it yeah so miss
Kidman yes this is technically your
return to DC movies you were in Batman
Forever yes way back when
what what was it
about sort of the superhero genre that
said you know what I want to I want to
give it a go again I want to be another
one of these kinds of movies
well James offered me the Queen can't
say no to being a queen so so yeah that
was and to be able to work with him I
loved everything he's done and to be
able to work with all these gorgeous
people I was just like yeah I would love
to and I want to do a film that my kids
can see yeah I do so many things that I
have to say no you can't do that so this
is this gives them so much great at
school the boys the boys at school are
now like giving Sunday props they got
the street cred right now yeah they go
you are in the movie right I am you know
the trailer just dropped and it's
visually just stunning yeah and so James
I want to just ask you for you know the
visual inspiration for this film just
underwater in Atlanta it's just some of
this numb the creatures it just looks
extraordinary and just can you speak to
me a minute about the the influences
well I mean the biggest influence and it
was it's pretty organic you know we pull
a lot of the visual inspiration
aspirations from from you know from the
sea from the ocean itself right you know
just basing things on the creature on
maritime creatures and and landscape and
world creation based on what we feel a
civilization down they were built so
there wouldn't be a they wouldn't build
houses or architectural buildings out of
you know wood and steel they would
probably grow it and coral you know and
there'll be bioluminescent to be organic
and so I said that was the starting off
point and from there we just keep
growing it and growing it naturally
right on you know amber I feel like
there's gonna be a lot of little girls
this Halloween dressing up as mirror you
know and Wonder Woman was I think kind
of the leading kind of influence for
leading ladies in the DC EU and sort of
who are your influences when you took
over this character who did you look at
any kind of other characters or other
actresses that kind of influence your
performance
the way you played this role well I love
I love what gal did that with Wonder
Woman I love how she was handled by the
studio with the film makers and
protecting the integrity of the kind of
characteristics that we really need to
see more of in female characters across
the board but especially in the comic
book and action genre so I'm excited to
see a different type of woman I
different you know I'm excited to see
the energy behind seeing these more
fleshed out fuller stronger more
empowered females represented in this
genre as well as others so I'm really
excited that we're doing it and I feel
really supported to be among filmmakers
and other artists that also feel like
that is something that we have to bring
out more of right on right on I'm coming
over
Black Manta yeah yeah I have seen so
much Black Manta fan art yeah people are
into this character in singular so talk
a little bit about black mended now I
know I had spoken to James and James you
said this is an origin story for Aquaman
but also an origin story for Black Manta
and so who is this guy when we meet him
man at the beginning of it you know he
is I like to see I like to consider
these guys good guys also you know he's
a guy with a UH with a plan and a
mission in life and he runs into a big
problem he talks about being you know a
big part of that problem that sets him
on for revenge and you said that the
fans were so excited about this I've
been having a really good time going
back and forth and talking with the fans
and you know hiding what the costume was
gonna be like that's the biggest thing
that's causing all the buzz you know
where's the suit look like what the suit
look like you know I've seen it with
spandex you know a huge dome on his head
you don't have a channel enormous hair
you know the garbage can there's so many
versions my favorite but there's that
shot in the trailer where you just see
full black bear man yeah man what was it
like seeing that shot seeing that come
to you it was awesome I mean I I lost my
mind I feel like I feel like I'm one of
the fans and I have been I've been on
the edge of my seat even though I'm
already you know I know what it looks
like I know everything but I still I
still want to see the suit you know I'm
like James release
a little story when Yaya came in to do
additional ADR for the film additional
dialogue for the film he heard what we
did to his voice when he was inside the
suit and he just went ballistic it was
literally jumping across the stage like
a little kid in a candy store yeah it
was super cool yeah exciting for me as a
director to see that Patrick let's come
over to you there's a really cool kind
of throne battle like a Throwdown
between your two characters in that
trailer talk about warm how they
separate himself from like other kind of
sort of sibling rivalries or you know
that kind of that kind of vibe that
we've seen in films before like what's
different about this character and what
he brings to it well I mean yeah the the
the sibling rivalry I think is a given I
think they're the the tension of being
the full-blooded atlantean versus the
half-breed I think that's that all that
anger all that violence is actually
pretty easy to play and I think what was
interesting it's something that James
tapped into is is the had this worked
out another way when maybe when they
were kids maybe if they had met earlier
maybe if the world would have been
different then then maybe they would
have got along and I think it's without
being too sappy I think playing when
you're playing a scene that's got a lot
of hate if you play the love it makes it
that much more the tension that much
greater because like James always says
you want to invest in the characters and
that's something that James is really
conscious of and as for we because
there's a lot of fights spoiler alert so
so we go at it pretty good a lot of us
do but the interesting thing and what
the what the movie brings you know I
can't speak to other other superhero
films wasn't I've been it but that it it
it it it comes from a place of love you
see where these guys maybe maybe had had
paths and then that just veered veer
veered off and now can they ever get
back together if that's for everyone
though also it didn't mean literally you
could say that for everybody thinks in
that every character yeah you know there
there's Atlantis isn't the only Kingdom
we go to some other kingdoms in this
movie and so I'm curious Jason if you
had your own Kingdom Jason Momoa Kingdom
what would that
that look like it would have a lot of
Guinness
yeah sharp objects lots of fun lots of
meat fire a lot of Carhartt and a lot of
rock climbing wall yeah it's a good
place to go
this kid man if you had a Kingdom very
different why yeah kind of similar maybe
not so much Guinness diamonds and joy
what do you think is gonna surprise fans
the most about this movie and when they
walk out what do you want them talking
about world like we haven't seen this
before the technology you know I mean
there's so many things there's there's
the emotional story there's the journeys
that every character take I'm really
looking forward to seeing the technology
how does this underwater world come to
life there's times when it looks like
Indiana Jones there's times where it
looks like a Star Wars there's times
where it looks like something that I
haven't even seen before and I think I
think that's one of the things that the
fans are gonna take away from it also
right on where there's some super strong
performances and I there's so much
laughs so you can see it we're not
faking anything we had a great time the
script was amazing from the get-go he's
a genius sorry so he it's gonna it's
amazing and and and and the truth of it
is like there's moments where it's just
super tender and you're gonna be you're
gonna see what this guy came from and
what he went through I think people are
gonna be all the identify there 'he's a
whole whole bunch of kids out there they
don't have something that can identify
what i think there's a big thing that I
know responsibility to to be someone
that was kind of an outsider and really
identify with yes and first
brown-skinned superhero come on
yeah on that goat this December the
biggest movie of the year
Rock will man hits theaters give it up
for the cast about man
[Applause]
you